emmanuel macron ne souhaite pas être un
président en serre est enfermé dans le
palais de l'elysée d'ailleurs vous le
voyez bien dans ses déplacements de
ministres et même deux candidats et
parfois ça donne des images qui n'ont
pas toujours à son avantage mais il aime
aller au contact
voilà quand il est placé comme il de
l'économie s'il y avait un piquet de
grève ou des gens qui manifestaient il
aller au contact
il va discuter il aime le contact direct
il aime la confrontation et surtout plus
que la confrontation la pédagogie
égouttez le ressenti des uns et des
autres s'entendre dire ce qui à leurs
yeux de aux yeux de nos concitoyens ne
va pas et leur apporter des réponses en
prendre note et c'est ce ne sera pas un
président médiatique ce serait un
président à l'écouté et à l'action il ya
encore des choses dont on a besoin de
savoir sur cette personnalité ce
président qu'il sera et biographies qui
sort dans les prochains jours deux
confrères françois-xavier bourmaud du
figaro il décrit aussi comme quelqu'un
qui a un côté très dur
c'est quelqu'un qu'on ça c'est quelque
chose qu'on n'a pas vu qu'on voit peu
est-ce que vous qu'il connaissait bien
il a ce côté dur oui oui c'est un homme
très exigeant avec lui-même et avec tous
les autres surtout lorsqu'il mesure que
c'est pour servir notre pays qui vient
tout de même un certain nombre de
préoccupations importantes et par
conséquent oui il sait être il sait être
dû rendre il faut être dur mais
n'oubliez jamais ça dur avec lui-même et
avec celles et ceux qui veulent servir
le pays nous